episode four is a whirl one and I'm
still hyperventilating after it's insane
ending there's a lot unpack here guys so
strap in and let's do this the episode
begins with snow which if you've been
following my other videos almost always
indicates a dream sequence or flashback
Henri sleeps experiencing some sort of
nightmare or more likely a flashback of
what happened to him in 1991 there are
glimpses of a cage in a dilapidated
basement someone's feet pop into frame
are they Henry's you can make out a blue
toy car and Holy Bible as well in the
top corner you can also see a row
similar to the one de Lacy used to kill
himself in episode 1 and which can also
be found in his garage in a flashback in
episode 2 the blue shoes with the red
laces here and the brown shoes here look
oddly identical to the shoes Henry finds
at Joseph des jardins home later on in
the episode so where is this basement
could it be Dale Lacey's the one we saw
locked in episode 2 or could it be
something we haven't seen yet consider
also the brief shot we get of young
Henry in episode 3 he isn't wearing blue
jeans and his missing-persons poster
says he was last seen wearing white head
sneakers is the person in this flashback
actually him a knife wielding figure
appears before Henry wakes up from his
nightmare Zaleski arrives at work
visibly unhappy and on edge he takes
over a shift from another officer who
remarks would it kill you to smile a
foreshadowing of things to come
Reeves intimidates the kid by telling
him a story about how he used to torture
terrorists in this scene we also get a
better view of the cell in pointing g FB
D which is an acronym for God forgives
brothers don't
there is also what appears to be a town
map lyrics to songs and the name David
Allan Coe who's an American
singer-songwriter I tried to search for
the poem in the corner here but couldn't
find anything if any of you have any
suggestions on what it might be I'd love
to hear about it in the comments the kid
spooks Reeves telling him quote he has a
name written on him which no one knows
except himself he is clothed in a robe
dipped in blood and his name is called
the Word of God this is an excerpt from
the book of revelations chapter 19 verse
11 this is referring to the second
coming of
Christ who descends from the heavens
riding a white horse not to be confused
with revelations chapter six which sees
the Antichrist riding a white horse
this distinction furthers my suspicion
that the kid is on the side of good on
their way to his father's grave Allan
inquires as to who will be the judge on
the kids case considering Allan's
connection to Dale him wanted to know
this information confirms his interest
in the kid you'll also notice the song
playing on the cassette tape is the same
song Gene Pitney 's twenty four hours
from Tulsa that he puts in his car back
in 1991
Henry is given a map of the grave site
from the Kennebec cemetery grounds
manager a map which has the word
potter's field on it this could be a nod
to the medieval mystery novel of the
same name which revolves around the
discovery of a dead body in a field in a
land dispute between the main character
and the church kind of like how Allen
and Henry argue who has the rights over
the home Ruth and Matthew Devers body
coincidentally the king in this story is
named King Stephen or if you flip it
around Stephen King as they venture
toward the grave you can make out dots
on the map which look eerily similar to
those found on the map and the kids sell
Henry tells Allen that he's planning on
bringing Ruth back with him to Texas
where she'll be put in a home he
insinuates that Allen and Ruth had an
affair which is why he wanted Matthews
body up in the middle of nowhere he
questions Allen what he was really doing
up there looking for Henry in 1991 even
though the search for him had been
called off did Allen have secondary
motives for finding him when Allen
arrives home an episode of The Twilight
Zone called the howling man is on TV in
this episode of man seeks shelter in a
monastery during a storm the monks of
the monastery claimed that a howling man
they have imprisoned is the devil the
man doesn't believe the monks and
eventually frees him only for him to
find out that the man is actually the
devil is this an allegory for the kid in
day lacy Allen brings up Texas to Ruth
who says absolutely not she references
the scale Mara connection to shield
maidens from Norse mythology the shield
meanings are said to be the precursor to
Valkyries mythical warriors who decided
who lived and died in battle the
Valkyries bring their chosen to the
afterlife in Valhalla or Norse heaven
how this might manifest itself later on
could prove to be important
it would also explain all the posters of
iceland around her house Henri meets
Molly and tells her about the kids
$300,000 settlement offer from Shawshank
as the wait plays on the radio which
talks about Nazareth the city in Israel
where Jesus grew up we get another quick
daydream from Henry where we see what
appears to be the captor holding a cane
now it's unclear if this guy is missing
any fingers which would point at vince
de Chardin who we'll learn about a bit
later on there are also two quick shots
giving off what looks like heat
signatures which could possibly just be
the flashlights reacting to the film
grain I'm not sure but I thought it was
pretty cool so les key pulls Henry aside
and gives him a pitcher he drew of the
cage he found in the water tank to be
used as evidence in the hearing he
expresses his distaste for how things
are run in Shawshank saying bad [ __ ]
happens because bad people know they're
safe here this is followed by shots of
Zaleski witnessing police brutality
within the confines of Shawshank Zaleski
meets with the kid and tells him once he
testifies they're both getting out of
here the two touch via fist bump this
touch is important because after this
point though less key slowly begins to
show signs of going insane moments later
drawing smiley faces all over the
security cameras the effects of the kid
touching others is also seen in episode
two when Henry warns the skinhead how
and to what extent does the kids touch
affect others perhaps his touch
accentuates the evil in others at the
county clerk office Henry sifts through
old newspapers the first is an article
highlighting the new warden Dale Lacey
who is quoted as saying I feel I've been
preparing all my life for this role
which I believe to be a calling funny
how God works
the second is an article about Dale
Lacey's prisoner rehabilitation program
where the state pays prisoners $2 an
hour to take on much-needed rolls around
Castle Rock like fire fighting and road
building in Episode two Martha even says
Dale believes in rehabilitation off the
clock he called it grace the third makes
reference to the Christmas fire of 1987
where we learned the fire was
deliberately set by an unnamed person
who was detained coincidentally Alan
Pangborn then Chief of Police was the
first on the scene and pastor Matthew
Deaver conducted the
memorial for the 28 killed the final
article is about Henry's disappearance
and how the prisoners in Lacey's
rehabilitation program aided in the
search I can't help but imagine there's
a connection there the article makes
reference to Vince de Chardin being a
potential suspect he was one of aces
gang members in the body also known as
stand by me apparently he got out of
prison one month prior to the
disappearance and secluded himself in
the woods near where Henry was found at
the bottom of the page we see the same
article lacy cut out and was found in
his file folder in episode 2 this was
the one about Leland gaunt and another
suspicious fire at the Deaver home Henry
questions Ruth about why they never
talked about his disappearance she
deflects exploding on him in an angry
tirade about why he would send her to a
home in Texas I think of it every time I
see balloons molly is selling Martha and
daily sees home but fumbles when the
potential buyers discovered Dale Lacey's
cremains in the freezer Molly tells them
it's not a big deal not like anyone died
here unlike her home where a strangler
committed suicide another nod to Frank
Dodd the strangler from the dead zone
Henry visits vince de Chardin but finds
no one home he does find a creepy box in
the woods with a rotting bowl of cereal
in it he's interrupted by joseph de
chardin Vince's brother who inherited
the home from him and now runs a barber
shop when Joseph finds out he's Henry
Deaver he takes him upstairs and gives
him the police file from his
disappearance back in 1991
files the police say were destroyed in a
flood and that day Sharda have been
keeping because he wanted to see what
they said about him all a little cryptic
to say the least
Henry ass offense had a dog because of
the wooden box out back he says no but
it makes me think of the dog from
episode 1 & 2
Joseph ends the scene by saying you know
I never touched you which could mean two
things either Joseph had a reputation as
a child abuser or was somehow involved
in his disappearance by aiding those who
actually did all-in-all anyone who has a
piano through their ceiling is creepy as
hell here we see Matthew Devers casket
exhumed armed with the police file Henry
confronts Alan about not properly
investigating Desjardin during his
disappearance
Allen drops a bombshell on Henry stating
that on Matthews deathbed he wrote Henry
did it and that Alan had been covering
for him all these years but did that
even happen
is Alan lying and if he wasn't was
someone else controlling his signature
or could the sentence be referring to
something entirely different we'll have
to put a pin in that one for now Henry
accuses Alan of being a liar and that
all he's in for is his mom and house
Molly takes a pill to drown out the
sounds of Alan and Henry's argument
which she also has apparently heard
right as Henry shows up on her doorstep
Henry questions if he actually killed
his father and that he should never have
come back to Castle Rock in the first
place Molly tells him it wasn't his
fault before following it up with you
were just a kid right now she seems to
be the only one who knows what happened
to him in that forest but she's not
telling the next morning Henry's in
Molly's bed implying that they likely
slept together the Thunder outside for
shadows the events to come Henry calls
Zaleski and tells them there's been a
change of plans
Ruth sees her husband's body brought
back to the church but her face looks
one more of fear than of sadness or
anger is there something in that casket
she doesn't want others to see or rather
something in that casket she doesn't
want out at Shawshank Zaleski checks his
phone and learns henry has decided to
take the settlement offer and leave town
then in the most shocking event on the
show yet Zaleski goes on a rampage
marking X's on the security cameras
methodically planning his targets every
person Zaleski kills is a crooked or bad
cop
none of them being prisoners the two
deaths of note are Reeves and Boyd both
of whom who've been terrible to the kid
is a Leske merely a vessel doing the
will of the kid if so how come he marked
an x on Henry's camera or is that just
referring to warden Porter's office
likely the latter since Celestine ever
points his gun at Henry what's even
crazier is comparing the security camera
footage from episode 1 to episode 4 this
is episode 1 Zaleski's apparent dream
and here is episode 4 did Celeste key 4
see his own massacre can dreams in
Castle Rock not only be of things from
the past but also predict things in the
future and
who or what is making them possible
Zaleski is killed from a gunshot blasts
which bursts Henry's eardrum the sound
drowning out and mimicking the same
noise Allen Pangborn heard before
finding Henry at Castle Rock Lake in
1991 Celeste Keys murder spree comes as
a shock because it's unexpected
what soon-to-be father with dreams of
becoming a lawyer gets up and goes on a
rampage Celeste II was controlled by
someone or some thing in all signs at
this time point to the kid this was one
of the craziest episodes yet spending
most of its time building new mysteries
around Castle Rock and paying off with
an explosive ending how will this event
keep Henry and Castle Rock and what's in
store for our characters in the wake of
such an event make sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more Castle Rock videos I
think we've just hit the tip of the
iceberg with this show and I'm excited
for even more as always leave your
theories and comments below let me know
what I missed and stay tuned for another
video coming soon